is everything you know and love dying
right before your eyes
let's find out
[Music]
all right you might have guessed it but
I'm gonna be talking about some Hoodie
orgs today but what you might not know
is that we're also a hoodie orc go down
and click in the link in the description
and get yourself one of our dope touch
grass hoodies there is one question that
has been sitting in the soft underbelly
of the Esports and gaming world over the
past few months is Esports dying now for
me a lot of the Resurgence of this
question follows the downward momentum
of FaZe Clan's decidedly odorous initial
public offering back on July 20th of
last year for those of you who don't
know an initial public offering or IPO
is what happens when a business takes
their company public and allows people
to buy and sell their shares on a stock
exchange and if you're wondering how
faze's stock has been doing since that
fateful July day well you don't have to
be a financial analyst to analyze this
chart since its debut on the NASDAQ the
shares in phasing up have completely
tanked and that has contributed to a
much larger conversation in the Esports
gaming World about just how orgs and
Esports become profitable businesses you
see many of the biggest Esports orgs
that you know love and cheer for are
propped up by speculative investment a
bunch of rich people out there in the
past said to themselves hey this Esports
[__] could be pretty big and then
invested in those orgs in order to give
them the cash that they needed to grow
the problem is while many of those orgs
have grown have developed fan bases and
big audiences there's just one thing
missing
how the [__] do they make money now in
order to answer that question let's do
what every Boomer has been doing for the
last five years when considering Esports
compare it to traditional Sports a
traditional sports team like oh I don't
know the future of 2023 World Series
champion Toronto Blue Jays makes money
in a few ways we've got advertisement
merchandise sales TV deals ticket deals
licensing and revenue sharing and with
that in mind many people including the
early investors and things like the
OverWatch league and the LCS thought
that they could replicate this model and
create what might be a very profitable
merchandising and media business the
problem is that so far it hasn't worked
and with many mainstream Brands choosing
not to re-up as title sponsors of
leagues like that it doesn't look like
it's going to work anytime soon so with
very few exceptions all of your favorite
Esports orgs are still riding the high
of that venture capital investment all
while trying desperately to find ways to
make money and paying salaries of
players that are probably deservedly
very high and you don't have to take my
word for it just ask this guy's toast
toast assembled the ballot roster just
before the recent n a Challengers lcq
and after a heroic run from a young team
who had really only been together for a
month they qualified for challenges
which Left Post with one important
question you might find this one
familiar and he took it one step further
than that he actually made a YouTube
video explaining the entire story of
signing this roster from start to finish
how he signed the team how much it costs
and ultimately how daunting it is to try
to recoup that cost as an org owner
which gave me two months to you know
create a new company sign a coach sign
five players and hope they have enough
time left to practice and win this whole
thing how hard could that be so with
each player costing 5 000 bucks minimum
the coach is also you know similarly
priced you're looking at
thirty thousand bucks a month which is
three hundred and sixty thousand dollars
a year minimum and again this doesn't
include any other staff you might need
like designers like stuff like
accountants and lawyers to look over
these contracts add everything up and
that's at least half a million dollars a
year as you can see from toast napkin
math this [__] ain't cheap as these
Sports become more and more mainstream
popular the biggest events are massively
watched and the players are able to
command even more competitive salaries
let's put ourselves in toe shoes and go
back to our early example of traditional
sports franchises he's not going to be
signing any hundred million dollar TV
deals anytime soon he's not a franchisee
so he's not going to be doing any
Revenue sharing with Riot so the best
that he can hope is to package himself
and his team together and sell some ads
or make some hoodies and sell those but
surely a Creator backed org run by one
of the most respected figures in the
industry not mentioned handsome as hell
would be able to eventually turn a
profit right for those that don't know
I'm sure most of you know by now I own
an Esports org called moist Esports and
I [__] love it I am extremely
passionate about moist Esports but I run
it at a massive net loss I don't want to
get too deep into the nitty-gritty here
too deep into the weeds and the brass
tacks but I lose roughly six figures a
month on it and it's fine so yeah I
guess you could say that this just keeps
getting worse if you're not aware toast
is of course referring to moist
criticals creatorback Esports org moist
Esports which Charlie himself says he's
running at a six-figure loss per month
and moist has teams and players in
rocket League Apex Legend Guilty Gear
and smash not even the biggest Esports
where the players and staff would be
demanding the highest salaries and you
might say to me Keith you're describing
two small orgs that are backed by
individual creators assuredly this isn't
happening with those big words that you
described earlier that are all backed by
investment money and Venture Capital
well let me tell you about the week that
100 thieves just had on February 7th
Tech website digiday published an
article in which they interviewed six x
100 thieves employees about the
company's recent round of massive
layoffs in their content creation
Department the article discusses an
alleged internal pivot within the
organization one that moved their
business model away from YouTube first
content Creation in Partnerships into a
strategy that was focused on creating
and acquiring new businesses over the
last little while 100t and nadeshot have
launched an energy drink called juvie
started a game Studio acquired
peripheral company High Ground And of
course continued to expand their
clothing and merchandise footprint You
Know Hoodie org etc etc the article
colors nadeshot and the company in a
little bit of a darker shade than usual
it also paraphrases a former employee
making the accusation that nadeshot and
their executive team are prioritizing
passion projects like juvie over their
traditional money making Partnerships
business and this is where things get
complicated for me because as someone
who creates YouTube content in Esports I
don't want to see anyone losing their
jobs on the other hand if nadeshot and
his executive team believe that there's
no path to profitability in Partnerships
and content creation even if it is more
lucrative in the short term then they
absolutely should pivot because if they
don't make the change then eventually
the whole company will lose their jobs
this content model it's not a new model
you create an org you get some players
the players become popular you create
content around those players then you
try to sell that content to Brands maybe
even stick their logo on your jersey but
if that strategy isn't going to keep up
with your 120 million dollars in venture
capital investment and 460 million
dollar evaluation and you think that hey
what if we sell some energy drinks some
hoodies some video games and maybe some
keyboards and that will keep up then
maybe that's what you got to do okay so
before we move on to maybe a few of the
Rays of Hope in this Rat's Nest of a
situation let's do a little recap rich
people were like hey cool Esports let's
invest nadeshot did that cool pose with
Drake that one time if you remember the
question arises how do we make any money
off of this phase goes public last
summer and completely tanks and now
we're all left sitting here going is
there any hope well I have two less
gloomy paths forward that I'd like to
discuss with you enter
Ludwig I guess oh winning yeah hard work
perseverance life liberty pursuit of
Dubs the whole nine
just Champions over here okay I get it
moist is super successful you don't have
any crypto sponsors but don't get to
burn a lot of money to win that much
didn't Susan give you a lot of money to
burn
so you just burn the money like this
despite moist literally making YouTube
videos explaining all the money he was
losing on moist Esports Ludwig recently
announced that he had signed on and was
going to be a co-owner of the orc and
according to the man himself this is why
he did it I like Esports I know I talk
[__] on it all the time but my ideal
Sunday is sitting down having football
on one monitor Esports and the other
monitor and chess on my main monitor
while like tank ELO and watch my
favorite teams win or usually lose and
this is how he feels that moist Esports
could actually make some money but
outside of passion and wanting to work
with Charlie I also think there's some
possibility that it could make money
because I think we have an advantage
that most teams don't the same advantage
that somebody like this guy's toast
would have which is the exact tweet I
sent out to him a week ago about the
same topic
we're all content creators and in this
space where every single venture
capitalist group freaks out gushes and
comes their little pants at the sentence
Creator economy we have a lot of
Leverage a lot more than an Esports team
like you know
well I guess I shouldn't name any
because they're my competitors now but
like another Esports team who's not
creator-backed now obviously Ludwig is
being optimistic here he's a big name
with a lot of money he's trying to do
something cool with one of his friends
and hopefully they can make some money
together but I do think he makes a
strong argument there are very few
things in this space more powerful than
a big megaphone and Ludwig has one of
the biggest moist will now be able to
package up their Esports offering with
the viewership and fan basis of both
moist critical and Ludwig and take it to
Brands and say hey this is probably
something you want your name attached to
and the fact is they're not wrong and
crucially he's also stressing creating
products and merchandise and using those
big megaphones to sell them something
that 100 thieves is literally being
criticized for ultimately Ludwig and
moist are passionate about Esports and
for me
that's all this really comes down to
there's not going to be some magical
money fairy that comes down and makes
this all better at the end of the day
it's going to take risks from the people
that can actually afford to take those
risks to make this [__] work out which
brings me to my last and maybe my most
important Point let's talk about the
role that the developers play in all of
this because unlike traditional Sports
Riot games and the developers that make
these Esports titles literally own the
product that all of these businesses are
trying to build around nobody is putting
patch notes out for basketball and
that's a lot more relevant than you
might think at first glance the fact is
leagues like the NFL and the NBA have a
rooting interest in the success of their
Orcs when the LA Lakers are successful
and popular the NBA can then sell that
to broadcasters and advertisers and make
money Riot on the other hand well they
obviously have a vested interest in
Esports succeeding yada yada whatever
they're still going to make money hand
over fist selling knife skins to 12 year
olds in valorant whether or not Esports
lives or dies so as you can see
companies like Riot and valve and other
developers they've got a lot of power in
all this and ultimately the question of
how and when these Esports orgs make
money might just come down to the extent
to which the developers allow them to
profit off of fair intellectual property
the games themselves a good example of
this is the various Revenue sharing
programs that have been built across
Esports the recent VCT skin bundles R6
charms CS go stickers CDL skin bundles
and Street Fighter League Skins are all
examples of products that developers
have created and sold as a way to infuse
their Esports teams and players with
Revenue now I'm not saying that these
are currently driving enough Revenue to
keep an entire org's lights on but it's
obviously a step in the right direction
and perhaps this is why Riot games
completely rebuilt their franchising
model for the VCT where they asked teams
for literally zero dollars in stark
contrast to the millions that teams had
to pay okay to get into the LCS and the
OverWatch League back in the day maybe
the system is somewhat of an Olive
Branch from the developer to the Orcs
where Riot is obviously going to profit
off of the long-term viability of
Esports and they don't want to [__]
these orgs from the onset and honestly
the brass tax is that's what this all
comes down to from creators like Ludwig
to massive multinational corporations
like Riot if the Esports puzzle is going
to be solved we need all hands on deck
now I know I just kind of spelled out
doomsday for you but I'm trying to stay
optimistic because there is really
something pretty cool here going on with
Esports and there are a lot of
passionate really intelligent people
working their asses off to make sure
that we can watch simple wield his awp
for years to come
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock